Speaker 1: OK, we have the next iteration
of Grift from the former President Donald
Trump.
Donald Trump is now asking supporters to donate
$45 each in order to quote solve the election
fraud.
Now, you might still be wondering, David,
sir, what election fraud are you talking about?
It's still they're still talk about 2020,
the nonexistent election fraud from the election
almost a year ago.
We're like two weeks from a year out from
the 2020 election.
That's the one.
OK, here's the letter that Donald Trump sent
to his supporters.
This is under the Save America PAC friend.
Did you see what President Trump said?
And then it includes the quote from Trump,
the statement from Trump from last week.
If we don't solve the presidential election
fraud of 2020, Republicans will not be voting
in 2022 or 2024.
It is the single most important thing for
Republicans to do.
Then they pivot to asking for cash.
The truth is, we need at least forty five
dollars from each Patriot reading this email.
Each patriot.
If we are going to have the necessary resources
to solve the election fraud of 2020, President
Trump is calling on you to donate to the Protect
Our Elections fund with your help will defend
our elections from the lying left and win
big in 2022 and then again in 2024 and then
a link.
Please contribute at least forty five dollars
or more immediately to the Protect Our Elections
fund.
Now we've seen this grift before.
They're advertising hay with at the low, low
price of $45.
You can help overthrow the will of the people
because obviously Joe Biden won in 2020, but
it's not even that the goal is not an admirable
goal, that it's a goal based on lies and deception.
This is a grift.
Remember when Trump was raising money with
the same type of rhetoric between November
and January 20th and between November and
December 14th and then January 6th than January
20th?
The money didn't go to recounts.
The money didn't go to audits.
The money didn't go to fighting election fraud.
The money went to Trump to helping Trump pay
off debts.
That's what it was.
These people got scammed.
It was what we saw between November and January,
but then it didn't stop its continuing.
We are a year out, folks.
If you believe that the $45 you donate to
Trump is actually going to be used to fight
election fraud, then you deserve to be scammed
and drifted out of your money.
Trump, by the way, Trump must be in real trouble
financially as we believe him to be a year
out and still milking this like, even for
his standards, this is a lot.
And when we ask, will Trump supporters ever
realize there was no fraud?
Probably not.
They're going to believe there was election
fraud for a long time.
Will Trump supporters ever realize the fraud?
Is this grift fundraising being undertaken
by Donald Trump?
Some of them did.
There were a couple of big donors to the of
fixed take back the election, whatever fund.
There were a couple of big donors back.
We talked about it earlier in this year who
sued to get their money back because they
realized that the money wasn't actually used
for that, so some seemed to be coming to that
realization.
But the projection here seems deliberate,
right?
Trump is the guy who threatened secretaries
of state and said, You've got to find me the
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty votes.
He messed with the Postal Service to try to
make it less likely that absentee ballots
would be delivered on time.
He incited an insurrection.
He extorted Ukraine for political dirt on
his opponent.
He filed dozens of frivolous lawsuits through
Rudy Giuliani and these different lawyers.
He said, Stop the counting here.
Start the counting there.
He weaponized COVID regarding the mail in
ballots.
He's the guy who tried to steal the election
if there was fraud and dishonesty.
It was Trump who did it.
But they don't care.
They are the ones now being told it was the
Democrats that did it and give me money and
I will go and fix it for you at a certain
point, they deserve to be separated from their
money.
And listen, the government shouldn't step
in by their own standards because that would
be the nanny state if they decide, I'm going
to donate to this, it's caveat emptor, right?
And that should be it.
And many of these people are falling for it,
unfortunately.
And this really is sad.
A lot of the people donating to these different
funds and sending $45.
They really can't afford it.
They're not high income folks, not folks with
a lot of disposable income.
And that that's probably the saddest part
of all of this, quite frankly